oh wow
um
okay
uh you guys beat Joe Rogan which is
unexpected especially in uh three days
that
that was surprising I'm not going to
dwell on just how desperate some of you
may be and I'm just gonna say
congratulations however
some of you may have celebrated a little
early if you don't recall all the
conditions let me remind you you were to
get distractible the number one on
Spotify which you did beating Joe Rogan
in the process very impressive you were
to get go to number one in sports which
you did very impressive but the other
unmet condition was to get distractible
to number one in apple podcasts
and as of right now distractible is it
number six
but I'm not unfair and I do recognize
the efforts that you have put in you've
exceeded my expectations so I have come
to renegotiate the contract and offer
you a new condition to meet for my only
fans to be a reality and only when you
meet this new condition will I start my
only fans and provide you with the
promised tasteful nudes in the
description you'll find a link that will
lead you to a documentary called
Markiplier from North Korea which is
based off of the story that my own
mother wrote I and my friends
painstakingly made this documentary for
you to tell the story of my mother yes
I am perfectly willing to sell my body
to support my mom's efforts and work you
would do the same
or at least I would hope so and pride is
nothing in the face of Dishonor and I've
weighed the dishonor of starting and
only fans to the dishonor of not getting
people to watch my mom's documentary and
I have found tasteful nudes to be
tolerably dishonorable I could tell you
that it's an incredible story I can tell
you that we flew to Korea to film a lot
of it and I can tell you that I learned
a lot of Korean just to be able to talk
with my family which was an enriching
experience through and through but I
know that doesn't matter to you
you want to see me naked
you want the only fans
I know that I get that now
in the description there's a link sign
up and be there November 13th and watch
all together with everyone here to see
my mom's story before your very eyes if
you don't not only will you not get your
only fans but you'll make my mom
disappointed
she's already disappointed in me
do you want her to be disappointed in
you
click the link complete the bargain and
all of your only fans dreams will be
yours